my first year at Cal U was a bit rocky
okay let's talk about groan --is--
season two and how things are gonna pick
up from season one what's gonna be
different well first of all I have a new
roommate now okay
it is no me all right so that dynamic
already seems like polar opposites
huddling together
hello adulthood cool this is my
nightmare
so it's me know me and Zoey so it's the
three of us living in a brand-new
apartment which is really funny because
we all find ways to afford it and you'll
see that in the first episode how we try
to find ways to afford it and two
because Anna's very conservative and a
little bit in the bubble and and Nomi is
not it's very interesting just our very
first night there there are boundaries
that I'm really trying to to place and
no me just here's the opposite and she's
like okay cool more so more parties and
I'm like yeah so this is this sounds
like a roommate from from hell roommate
disaster and in Anna's mind yes Oh Mary
Kay yes
there is one one Squad gold literal
squad goal that I want to talk to you
about when you were on the bring it on
movie or do you and Solange and Hayden
Panettiere still keep in touch like that
was your money you just took me back
yeah but no Martina screams I actually
haven't seen Hayden at all and I noticed
she's not on social media or anything
she kind of like really stays low key
which I appreciate you've been in
Nashville so I don't really keep in
touch right and then Solange I actually
ran into her at the Billboard Women in
Music Awards last year when I presented
the award to Selena and we were walking
backstage and I haven't seen her since
the movie mm-hmm so I was like the
launch yeah this is like 10 years ago
yeah I was like hey so lunch
and she goes bring it on sister oh I
asked the photographer to take a picture
she's like I'm gonna take a picture with
my sister right here and I was like this
means a lot to me and I had that moment
with Rihanna - she was in the movie yeah
you took me back yeah yeah yeah Rihanna
was in the movie and so she saw me she
goes oh my gosh I haven't seen you in
years I'm like I'm so cool
and now is the st. Paris let guess there
is he stones repair sufficient now baby
let's shift back to grown --is-- because
we obviously know that Zoe and Luke are
now together so we have Zuka what is
that relationship gonna be like now that
they're not in the honeymoon phase
anymore are her friends helping her the
same way we did in season one okay I get
an earful all the time especially
because I'm her roommate and now she got
two four ears they're listening we hear
things every day and we're like Zoe calm
down okay stop being selfish leave him
alone mm-hmm play hard to get yeah we
definitely are there her girls for a lot
of drama that happens okay any love for
you this season I'm hoping so I'm hoping
so I put it out in the humerus we'll see
the writers actually don't tell us
anything
okay so course we just open the script
and in there you find out there I am
there I'm finding out so I know they're
teasing someone but they haven't told me
something oh man I hope in your
friendship circle that would be a little
sticky maybe I don't know it's single
okay she wouldn't never mess I'm sorry
love in Jordan but like the back is a
little much you know the drugs and stuff
like Anna Catholic yeah Republican
traveler opposite yeah he said you say
opposites attract though so that would
be funny
oh that would be crazy yeah be shocked
no I think you just put a pitch out
there there we go writers I know how it
is when you get your first finger
especially when it's with someone that
you love how much bilingual language are
we gotta see in season two um there's a
bit in there a writer's idea which I
really appreciate yeah writers idea and
we added in but I try to incorporate it
every now and then like sometimes kind
of have to improv a little bit when a
scene is starting and so one time it
actually brought me someone was
Colombian I was like let's talk in
Spanish really we had a whole
conversation in Spanish before the scene
started and kind of leading up to the
scene so little pockets that I throw in
there okay so they let that continue the
improbable of it Oh
no they love it and I really appreciate
free form for really encouraging that
because even in life size - there wasn't
any Spanish in it and Tyra was like girl
bring your culture in there so there's a
scene that I have with my mother in the
movie and they actually let me write a
lot of the Spanish dialogue Wow yeah
which is amazing so we kind of improv
that a little bit and so the because
when you talk to your mother you kind of
speak in Spanglish so I mean and she
there's a part where she yells at me and
she did it in Spanish and they kept it
there's no subtitles and it was really
really beautiful you do get Ben Sasse
there oh just throw a little shiny
object that graze and she'll be too
distracted to notice that her mother's
never around look Jess what mom I know
it is do you think that will ever have a
crossover of Tyra coming and guest
starring on grown --is-- I hope so I
would love that cuz I was trying to
figure it out I'm like she's on blackish
I mean it makes sense
yeah the cross the cross over makes
sense oh we have another fun crossover
happening this season really really
excited about I'm not gonna reveal who
it is oh yeah
hilarious
[Music]